LIONEL APETOH: I would say many individuals
like they are one way or the other familiar
with cancer and actually my mother
died of breast cancer. And my goal
is basically to try to endow T cells
with better anti-cancer properties.
LA:T cells are a subset of white blood cells that
are able to contribute to fighting off infections.
VOICE OVER: Lionel Apetoh is an immunologist that
has been studying T cells for more than 15 years.
LA: I got interested in T cells like because during my
PhD we were wondering to find how chemotherapies
could somehow, in precise situation, harness the
immune system. And I remember that was one of the
key experiments I did at the time, was to compare
how wild type mice, with a full immune system,
and immune deficient mice, lacking T
cells, respond to local radiotherapy.
And actually we found that T cells were essential
for the efficacy of chemotherapy. If mice were
devoid of those T cells they were not responding
as well as control mice to the treatment.
VO: T cells seemed to be playing a critical role in
fighting off cancer and Lionel was interested in
boosting those abilities, that led him to cytokines
signaling proteins that help control the immune
system; including binding to T cells and making
them more aggressive.
LA: We found so far that there is one subset of T cells that secrete a chemicalmediator like called interleukin 9 and
those T cells are particularly potent in
eliminating cancer cells.
VO: These cells knownas TH9 cells deal with cancer
by rallying overimmune cells to their cause. They secrete the
cytokine interleukin 9 which activates other immune
cells to bind to and destroy cancerous tumors.
TH9 cells appear to be particularly
effective at dealing with some tumors
in part because they keep their anti-cancer
properties longer than other kinds of cells.
So, Lionel has been trying to further improve
their abilities.
LA: So, we are trying to understandhow these cells develop, how we
can further enhancetheir anti-cancer properties so that then they
are really potent in eliminating cancer cells.
VO: Lionel and his team have found that cytokines are
not only produced by the TH9 cells but the cells
are also affected by different kinds of cytokines.
In fact, specific mixtures of cytokines
seem to improve their anti-cancer ability.
Lionel hopes to take samples of TH9 cells from a
person with cancer and convert them into better
longer lasting cancer fighters using cytokine
cocktails and then transfer them back into the
body to fight the tumor. But at the same time
it's a balance they can't be too aggressive.
LA: And clearly that's a challenge because those cells
might be somehow triggering like unwanted effects
or they might become harmful after transfer
to individuals. So, that's where it's kind of
a balance between like also aggressiveness
against cancer cells, not being harmful to
the cells of our own body.
VO: But it isn't justaggressiveness that Lionel needs to manage.
LA: But then, afterwards, after transfer to the patients like
what is important is that those T cells should be able to
keep those properties to mediate their anti-cancer
effect in the long run they should be able topersist.
I would be really happy to see, like in
terms of hope, like if we could transfer this
in the clinical setting. Our goal
would be to bring that to a phase one
first clinical trial and then, ideally, test
if those TH9 cells can be successful in treating
patients like in possibly phase two clinical trials.
I know the stakes and it's hard but sometimes
the hardest part was really like when I when
I meet with patients, because then, of course,
in a way it feels rewarding, because like we are
trying really to help them, but it's also very, like
on the emotional point of view, that's also a major challenge.
Because it shows also that we need to pursue, weneed to do better.
So, it's mixed feelingsbasically.
And if, like, we would be able, like, to
again come up with solutions for even like a small
portion of patients like I would really regard
this like personally as a major achievement.